ヘビの 11 2でしたけど
じゃあ一応ヘビの章 ヘビの章は
3番目 よー よー タンハン
ウダッチダ アセサン サリタン
シィグサラン ヴィソゥ・スィイグヴァー
ソー・ビックー・ジャハティ・ヨーラ・パーラン・ウラゴー・ジンナ・ニヴァ
パチャン・プーラナ で
3番目 この まあ一応この悟った状態を説明してるんですね
まあ心清らかになった状態
悟りの境地というものは
まあこちらではこの一番下の経典だから
このまあこの順番で悟るとかね
そういう概念もそれほどないんですね
この完璧にこの心清らかになった状態と言ってるんです
で 3番目 ヨータンハン
タンハというのは渇愛のことで
こちらは妄執と書いてますね
で 妄執でしょうかね まあ一応タンハというのは渇愛という
まあ物に囚われることですね
で 物でもよろしいし まあ物もそれだけではなくて
自分に対しても囚われていること
それからあの いろんな考え方とかね
自分の考え方という風に
まあ持っていることね
そういうものにも囚われていることがタンハなんですね
だから物に囚われることは
まあ分かりやすいんですよ
で 目で見られるものとかね
聞くものとかね 触るものとかね
そういう物に囚われると
で 人間っていうのはそういう物に囚われるだけではなくって
例えば目で何か見て それで喜びを感じる
まあそれにも囚われてまっちゃうんですね
自分の心で感じる この喜びに
で 結局は心で喜びを感じるんだから
物に囚われてまっちゃう
ですから それも渇愛し
それも捨てなくちゃいけないし
それからいろんなものを考えて
また人間が喜びを感じたりする
で まあそれも渇愛で それを捨てなくてはならないということ
ですから 悟った心っていうのは
何か意見にもとらわれてないし
何かものを見て まあいいものだったらいいものだと感じたりするし
悪いものだったら悪いものだと感じたりするかもしれませんだけど
まあそれも別に まあ通ったことなく囚われないんですね
だから悪いものは嫌なもので
それからもうもう嫌だから離れたいということも囚われなんですね
だから渇愛がなければ怒りも生まれてこないんですね
例えば 綺麗なものを見たいなと思う人に限って
綺麗でないものを見ると怒ったりするんですね
なんでこんなものを見なくちゃいけないんですか？と
ですから 怒りと欲っていうのはセットで
で 怒りが少ないんだったら
その分欲も少ない 欲が少ない人にとっては怒りも少ない
ですから まあ怒りだけなくしてほしいと普通は世の中で頑張っていたっても
まあそれは無理な話で
法則は知らないんだからね
で 自分がそっちを怒ってるんだけど
それは嫌ですよと なんとかならないかと聞きますけどね
で 怒りだけ取るということはできません
で 普通の世の中でこの都合が悪いんだから
怒りが悪くて気持ちいいものはいいんだと
で そういう風に話は甘くないんで
で もともとは喜びものは欲しいんだからこそ
そっち怒ったりするんです
だからすごい怒りっぽい人もものすごい欲張りなんです
で 現象の世界ではね まあ少々差が見えますけど
ある人はもうあまりにも楽しいことに重点を入れて
まあ悪いものはまああっち
まあいわゆる気にしない
まあ例えば人が喧嘩してると
まあまあそんなことはどうでもいいや
まあ楽しくやりましょうというふうに
この それはまあ置いておいて
楽しい方に持っていくかもしれません
怒らないかもしれません
それはまあ喜ぶことにすごく集中して重点を入れてるんですね
だからその人はもう器用ずるいというか
するがすごいというか
この喜ぶものが妨げるものはもう早くも丁寧に排除してしまう
そういう人々は世の中でよく見えるんですね
いつでもニコニコと楽しくいるんではないかなと
怒るんではないかなと
でも その人に怒りが消えたわけじゃないんですね
すごい活動やりますから
それ逆の人々もいるんですね
楽しいものは欲しいんだけど
いつでも楽しいものばっかり流れてくるわけじゃないんですね
物は楽しいものも楽しくないものもずっと流れてくるし
大体楽しいものよりも楽しくないものの量がかなり多いんです
ですから これあの 時間という流れも考えてみなくてないし
ですから 例えば 1 秒 1 秒 1 秒
自分の目に耳に体に触れるものはね
本当に楽しいものか 楽しくないものかと
ずっと一つ一つ見てみると
やっぱり 1時間以内で見たもの
1時間以内で聞いたもの
1 秒単位に分けてみると
たくさん聞きたくないものを聞いている
見たくないものを見ているということにはなるんですね
でも その人間がそのどちらに囚われているかというと
だからこの怒りっぽいの人が世の中で多いんです
すっごくニコニコ明るくしている人々は少ないんです
すごく少ないんです まあよく怒る人っていうのは多いんですね
そこでこの怒りっぽい人が
あの日常生活の中で眼耳鼻舌身意にくる情報は
まあ好ましくない情報が入ってくるんだから
それに攻撃しようとする
で そうすると 1時間以内の 1 秒単位で計算してみると
その人は怒ってしまう秒数が多いんですね
そこでニコニコしている人が
この流れてくる情報のいいものだけ取って
悪いと思うものは早く早くももうまあ気にしないで無視して置いておく
で それぐらいのことですから
明るく振る舞うのは難しいんです
怒って行動するのは簡単です
で いっぱい情報がありますから
怒るための業 ですから
この仏教で言っているこの瞬間論と一緒に考えなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから 一時間という我々知っている時間で見ても
一秒一秒一秒 この一時間以内でどのように生きてきたかなと思ったら
やっぱり好ましくない情報に触れた秒数が多い
ですから まあ怒りやすいんですね
そこでなぜ怒るかというと
やっぱり欲ないんですよ
すごい欲なんですね だから怒りだけ排除するということは無理なんですね
ですから 流れてくる情報をやめることはできませんね
我々の耳に流れてくる音をやめてもらうということは無理でしょうし
人の言葉をコントロールさせてもらおうとね
人間に優しい美しい言葉語ってもらおうではないかと思ったっても
これはもう無理 自分勝手に世界は行動してくれません
ですから この他のすべてのものはそういう風になっているんですね
だから 残っている方法というのは
やっぱり自分が何とかしなくちゃいけない
だから 悟る以前 一般に日常生活の中では
やっぱりまあみんな怒ることは良くないと分かっているし
欲は良くないと分かってないんですね
怒ることだけ良くないと分かってるしね
なぜかというと この世の中のたくさんのものを排除しようと壊そうとしちゃうと
そちらから攻撃が来てくるんですね
ですから 一時間以内でたくさんの時間
たくさんの秒数 もう相手に対して戦っていくんだから
向こう側から攻撃されるんですね
ですから 自分がもっとよりひどい目に遭っちゃうんですね
例えば一時間の中で まあ百秒ぐらい楽しいものはあったとしても
もう残りの秒数でも攻撃されちゃったんだから
それに攻撃してしまったんだからね
それからもっとさらにひどい目に遭ったりしますね
だから そこをわかってる人々は怒りよくないんだと言ってるんですね
だから まあそこはそうやって厳密にしゃべらなくてもね
怒ってたら喧嘩するは
怒ってから社会関係悪くなるは
家庭関係悪くなるは まあもう何にも動いてないし
それから体の中も悪くなっちゃうし
細胞も悪くなっちゃうし
頭も悪くなっちゃうしね
で 体の病気になってしまっちゃうし
で まあそういうことだから
まあ怒りよくないと思っている
でも欲はよくないと思っていない
怒りよくないと思っている
で 結構頑張りますね 怒りを排除しようと
で 排除できません 捨てたければ欲を捨てなくてはならないんですね
欲を捨てたら怒りも消えてしまっちゃうんですね
だから欲を捨てた人にとっては
目にどんな情報が触れても
耳にどんな情報が触れても
それを受け入れることもなく
排除することもなく もう流しちゃうんですね
まあ放っておくんですよ
反応 反応しないで で 放っておくということは
分かってない人にはできない
何を分かっているかというと
やっぱり全て自分の体も外の世界も幻覚であって
瞬間瞬間生まれて消えていくものであって
実体はないということが経験していないと流すことはできないんですね
そこら辺 それからお経に出てきますけどね
だからこれ大変なことで
まあ並の人にできるものでもないんです
この完全たる悟りっていうことはね
そういうことで お釈迦様にとっては渇愛という一言葉でも説明できるんですね
渇愛を捨ててしまえば
その人が この世もあの世も捨てているんだと
何にもとらわれず解脱しているんだと
例えば何ですかね この
えーと 例えばありますね
走り流れるもうすぐ そういう
人間は全部のブッダが見たいんですね
サリタンっていうのは流れていく
シーガサランっていうのは
まあサランっていうのは湖のことなんですけど
湖と流れるっていうことはあまり合わないんですけど
まあいわゆる水のすごい速く
ものすごいシーガンっていうのはものすごい勢いですという意味で
シーガサラン すごい勢いでサリタン流れていく
このヴィソサイットワーっていうのはもう干しすくすというからしですか
からしすくすという意味でヴィソ
ヴィソサイットワー だからまあ例えとしてはまあ大変立派な例えで
やっぱりこの人間生きてるとこの眼耳鼻舌身意という耳鼻
それから心 それずっと流れているんですね
情報は 目にずっと情報流れてる
耳にずっと情報が流れてくる
舌にもずっと情報が流れてくる
鼻にもいろんなずっと香りが振るってくる
まあそれよりもすごく体にいつでも体の感覚ね
分かってるんですよ 麻痺する瞬間ないんだからね
麻痺してしまったら その瞬間では体のことわからないかもしれません
だけど いつでも体っていうことはもう感じて感じて感じて生きているんですね
ですから この目と耳と体っていうものはね
かなり分かりやすくてね
止まることなく流れてる
流れてると 目が開けているたびまずずっと流れてる
目を閉じても それでも視覚は流れてくるんですよ
普通だったら ですから
体分からなくなったっていうことはなかなか無い
まあ瞑想して集中しちゃうと
時々分からなくなって
その流れがオフになる時はあります
で それ訓練できれば 訓練っていうこともないんだけど
それは能力次第ですけど
例えばこのいろんな変なもの
幻覚見える人々っていうのは
この結局はこの視覚の流れをオフにすることはできないんですね
目を閉じているんだからね
やっぱりそこをまた回転し始めて
視覚が生まれて 生まれて流れていっちゃう
で 聴覚をオフにしないといろんな音を聞こえたりするね
瞑想しちゃうと ですから
やっぱり音 音だと確認しておかないと
まあ幻覚生まれてしまっちゃうんですね
そこで何かに集中して
例えば膨らみ縮みだけでもよろしいし
何かに一つに集中していくと
他のところから流れてくる情報流れがこの意識のところでこのオフしちゃうんですね
で オフしちゃったら その瞬間で他のものはなくなったと
体がなくなって消えたと
という風に感じますね
で 時々部分的に足の方がなくなったとかね
で 体の方がなくなったとか
もうなんか全部消えちゃったとかね
そういう風には感じたりする
まあそう それは幻覚ではありません
なんか自分の体消える
あれ これ これは摩訶不思議やとか思うかもしれません
それは幻覚じゃないんで
それはまあ意識が一つだけ意識に
まあチャンネル 6つありますからね
ですから そこでこのチャンネルがオフになっちゃったら
そこで存在は消えちゃうんですね
だから存在っていうのは
こちらで意識はずっと傍流として流れていく
目の意識 耳の意識 それに情報というものは傍流として触れていく
というのは  6つの流れが触れていくことは
だからこちらから流れが来て
こちらから流れが来て触れちゃったら
違う流れが生まれてくるんですね
認識という流れ だから認識という流れに自我と言うんですね
自我ってですから個体ではなくて
6つの流れまとめて我々はまあ大雑把で言ってることなんですね
だから人間大雑把だから困ったもんなんですよ
科学者もまあみんな大雑把なんですね
だから厳密に物事を言うなんで
昨日の夜の勉強会で言ったのがなぜ仏教で無意識がないんですかと
無意識がないのは大雑把で喋ってないだからなんですね
ですから  1時間以内で人が考えたものをまとめて考えちゃうと
いろんなことを考えていたことを発見しますね
だから そうすると無意識
意識が発見するんだけど
瞬間瞬間に伸ばしてみると
一つその意識しかないんですね
だから我々はこうやって 6種類の意識の認識の流れを大雑把にまとめて
私は私は見たんですよと
私は苦しいんですよと
まあそうやって言う それでも自我が生まれるんであって
ものすごい単純なものなんですよ
それは ほんのちょっと理解すればないんだってことはわかるはずなんですけどね
ですから この この流れてくる 6つの方法から
このすごい勢いで流れてくる情報に対する 6種類のこの情報の流れに対して
渇愛はなくしてしまうと
ああ いいものはいいもの
いいものやと思わないことで
そこで悟りの境地なんですね
だから我々一般的に この普通の俗世間で平和で生きているためには
やっぱり一番気をつけてほしいことは
この意識の流れにも執着してはいけないんだと
みんな欲があるんだけど
あまり食べ物に執着してはいけませんと
そんなきれいなものばっかり追っかけていけないっていうぐらいは知ってるんですからね
おっと 音楽ばっかり聞いてダメですよと
ぐらいはみんな知っている
遊んだり楽しがったりすることはもうあんまり良くないんですよと
ぐらい いわゆる原義備七心を刺激することは
まあやってはいるんだけど
これやり過ぎも良くないということぐらいは知っている
だからそこをコントロールするために世の中に法律までありますね
不倫してはいけないとか
まあ麻薬を使ってはいけないとか
泥棒してはいけないとかね
で 痴漢ですか 痴漢は良くないとか
でまあいろいろ法律までできていて
そこら辺は良くないとわかってます
まあそこら辺でわかってるんだから
それほど世の中で犯罪なしに
まあ生きていられますけど
でも人間の世界の中でかなりトラブルがあるんですけど
そこに法律作ることはできないんですね
それどういうことかというと
考え方なんですね そういう考え方はいけませんというふうに法律作ることはできません
だから威張って思考の自由を語ってるんです
この私たちはこの執着は良くないと言ってますからね
見てはいけないと言ってるんではなくて
水着はダメやと一般的に言ってることだからね
まあ音楽はまあ別に まあどうったことないんだけど
これ朝から晩までずっとそればっかり執着して聞くなというふうに言ってることだからね
そういうことだから よく気をつけてほしいのは
この思考 考えること 自分が考えることはね
それにすごく囚われてるんですね
例えば私があの人 本当に嫌な人やと思ったら
それ自分の思考であって
妄想概念なんですね でもそれだけは捨てたくないんですね
それ自分が持ったことはもうすごい
ものすごい厳密に囚われてるんですね
だから怒ったりもする
宗教の世界の中でもお互いに喧嘩するのはそういうわけで
浄土真宗とテーラワーダの2人があったらもう喧嘩になってきますよ
テーラワーダの人はテーラワーダの概念が正しいと思ってて
向こうは向こうの概念が正しいと思って
そこでぶつかったりしますね
ただの概念なんですね
ただの思考ですから 意識の流れだけですから
そこにもとらわれてはいけません
ですから根拠はないんですよ
たまたま初めて浄土真宗を聞いて説得させたんだから
それは正しいと思ってるだけで
テーラワーダを聞いて説得させちゃったんだから
それは正しいと思ってるだけでね
別に何の根拠もあるわけじゃないんですね
実体あるわけじゃないんですね
ですから 我々の勉強したもの
我々の概念 世の中に対する
人に対する もう政治論ですとか
宗教 様々な頭の中にある概念も捨てなくてはならないんですね
で いろんなところで見られますね
例えばこの伝統的ないろんな芸術ありますね
その中でこの 何 何て言ったっけ
いろいろ流派がありますね
例えば花の場合も何々流とね
そこで ある流というものが
ものを勉強して習った人が
他のもののことを真似たり
ちょっとしたりすると
こちらが怒ったりするんですね
そんなことをやってはいけませんと
で 例えば歌舞伎というのは歌舞伎のやり方がありますね
で そこにそれもまあそれに色々アメリカの何か踊りを導入しちゃったら
これ大変なことで 大騒ぎになってしまっちゃいますね
歌舞伎役者も 例えばこの何でしたっけ？ヨーロッパのバレエとか色々ありますね
裸で踊るんだから あれはね
結局は 服を着ているんだけど
かっこ悪くて気持ち悪いんだけどね
で  まあそれも概念ですけどね
で 例えばこのもう体もう全部もうもう一応何かすごい肌にきつくついてる服を着て踊ってるんですね
男も女も で 日本の歌舞伎で
何 どこでしたっけ やってる時は
なんとか劇場ありますね
そこで すごい派手に衣装を着て踊ってるところに
もう一人役がああいう風な衣装を着てきたら
これ大変なことでしょうに
大騒ぎになるでしょうに
お客さんにも怒られるかもしれません
なんだこれはということで
そこで歌舞伎衣装を着てバレエ踊っちゃったら
またまあ これとんでもないということになるかもしれません
まあ一応まあ踊りも転がってしまっては骨が折れますからね
衣装いっぱいありますから
自分の衣装を踏んでしまっては
それ例に言ったことで
それを概念なんですよ
歌舞伎という芸術は もう裸同然な服を着て踊るものではないんだとかね
バレエだったら綺麗な衣装を着て踊るものじゃないんだっていうふうな概念であって
別に根拠あるわけでも何でもないもの
だから そのように我々はそういう世界に浸っても
この執着している概念いっぱいありますね
それによって喧嘩起きたりはする
トラブルが起きたりする
で 人を死んだりもする
たくさん人を死んでるのはそういうわけなんですよ
一番世の中でたくさんの今までの歴史の中でね
すごい人が死んでしまったのは
この概念にとらわれていたんだからなんです
だからすごい厳しいんですね
で お金と例えば中国が台湾は自分の島だと
で 欲張ってね あちらの財産も奪いたいんですけどね
それは財産だから戦争しないんです
それほど もし思考でぶつかっちゃったらもう終わり
もし台湾の人々が中国の政府を批判したならば
そちらの生き方考え方なんかはね
認めません とんでもないよと言ったら
次の日はもうみんな殺されると思います
だから 渇愛の場合は一番我々はこの世の中で平和で無事生きていきたければ
自分が考えていることにとらわれない方が
ものすごい無難なんですね
まあ次に
行きます ヨーマナンウダッバディアセサンナラセトゥンワスブッダラングマホーホーソービククジャハティオーラパランウラゴジンナニワタチャンプラーナヨータンナ
ンウデッチッダアセサンヨーマナンウダッバディアセサンナラセトゥンワスブッダラングマホーホー二行しかないんですけどね
二番目のポイントはこのマーナという
二番目ではなくて それは四番目ですね
で マーナの説明 マーナっていうのは何でしょうかね
こちらは狂慢と書いてますけどね
まあ同じ心の働きなんですけど
で マーナも結局渇愛から生まれるものなんですよ
例えば 耳に何か音くれる触れたりする
その音は心が綺麗な音という風に受け取ってしまう
で そこでここに綺麗な音があると判断する
私は綺麗な音を聴いて楽しかったという風に判断起きてしまう
そういう風な判断ずっと流れていくと
ものを見て 私が綺麗なものを見たと
私が綺麗じゃないものを見たんだと
美味しいものを味わったと
美味しくないものを味わったと
楽しかったり 気持ち悪くなったりしましたとかね
そうやってこの自分作る判断をまとめちゃうでしょうね
長い間 まとめると この私はということがものすごく固体固定してしまっちゃうんですね
私という幻覚 その私という幻覚から幻覚生まれること自体が狂慢なんですね
ですから 物事を一切判断することはと理解した方が
この経典の場合は厳密に語らなくちゃいけないんですよ
これもこういう経典というのは遊びじゃないんです
だからあまりにもやりたくないんです
なかなかもう人間の能力ではもう把握できる世界ではないんです
まあですから もっと簡単にわかりやすいね
まあ後の経典一番いいんですけど
これも釈迦様が一番最初に語ってしまって
それでお坊さんの間で
阿羅漢たちの間で ものすごく暗記して
言い伝えた もう宝物のような言葉なんですね
ですから この一番大事な宝物のようなこの言葉だけ残してあって
それに膨大な注釈がありまして
どのように理解するかっていうこと
ですから このいきなり読むものじゃないんで
とにかく仏教についてすごい理解
ゆっくりゆっくりゆっくり理解してから読んだ方がよろしいと思いますけどね
まあなんか順番 日本ではなんか逆になってしまっちゃって
みんな先にブッダの言葉や
で 理解しないところで
なんか理解したような気がするんだけどね
またすぐ忘れちゃう また読まなくちゃいけないしね
また忘れちゃうっていうことですからね
それでマーンなんですけど
教慢なんですけど  で 教慢っていうのは
やっぱり物事を判断する働き自体が教慢だと理解した方がいいんですね
だから 耳に音が触れたその瞬間でもう判断するんですね
最初の判断だから綺麗か綺麗じゃないか
いわゆる自分にとっては好ましいものか
好ましくないものかという 2つだけだから簡単ですよ
判断は 良いか悪いか ただそれだけ
それをもうすぐ感情でもう判断してしまっちゃうし
あるいはまあ性質というか
この種類によってね 例えば人間の耳と犬の耳が違いますから
もう生まれで決めちゃうんですよ
判断のパターンを 犬の耳に触れる音は
まあ犬は犬なりに綺麗か好ましいか好ましくないか判断しちゃう
人間が人間という性質というんでしょうか
あれは その種の問題で
で そこは決めると その上
人間の世界では教育やらもう人生経験やら
そういうものに基づいてまた判断変わったりしますけど
基本的な判断はみんな同じ
良いか悪いか良いか悪いか
それだけの判断 だから勉強してどうなるかというと
この良いか悪いかと判断するものはもう色変わるだけで判断は変わらないんですね
ですから いっぱい勉強して
いっぱい暗示かけられちゃって
例えばヨーロッパの文化とか音楽とかなんとかとかね
とことんとことん暗示かけられてしまって
しまったところで綺麗と判断する
西洋人にはそういう暗示かけなかったならば綺麗だと思わないと思いますけどね
で 音楽っていうのは人間の喜びを音で
まあ泣き声で表すことなんですよ
基本的には わめき声で
泣き声で表すことですから
ものすごい自然でなければ音楽にならないんです
でも ヨーロッパの音楽っていうのは
ものすごい必死の思いで
死ぬぐらい苦しむ 味合いながら歌ってるんです
自然な音じゃないんです
全て人工的に作り出した音なんです
だから本当に歌というならば
自然に人間の声から動物の喉から出る音であるはずなんです
そこはまあ別にどうったことないんだけど
勉強すると 我々はその音も綺麗な音だと判断して感動する
判断しなかったら感動しない
そこで他の文化の人々はもうあまり大したことないんだと
こちらで固定概念持ってるんだから
あっちこっち森の中で部族の人々はなんか歌ったり踊ったりするのは
もうあんなものはもう原始的で良くないとすぐ言ってしまっちゃうし
そういうアンチもヨーロッパからもうずっといろんなものを通して
他の文化をバカにする風に教えてるんだから
みんなそう勘違いしちゃう
まあとにかく人間の場合はそういう問題であって
基本的には問題ないんですよ
音はいいか悪いか判断するだけのこと
犬猫にもそれを教えることはできますでしょうにね
例えばおりんを鳴らしてぶん殴っちゃうと
犬はあの音は良くないんだと判断する
そうやって教えることはできます
言葉で言ったってわかりませんからね
ですから 良いか悪いか
目で見るものは良いか悪いか
耳で聞くものは良いか悪いか
舌で味わうものは良いか悪いか
体に入れるものは良いか悪いかと判断することは狂慢の働きなんですね
それは一番基本的な この修行でもってなくすのはそういうものなんです
そこで 俗世間ではもういろいろ狂慢いっぱいね
出てますからね 私は勉強しているんだと
あの人は勉強していないんだ
そういう判断ですからね
それも狂慢なんですね
あの人には収入がないんだ
私には収入があるんだっていう判断も
それによって問題が起きたりする
悩んだり困ったりする
あの人は綺麗だ あの人は綺麗じゃないかって判断によって
いろいろ問題起きたり悩んだりする
そうやってありったけの判断からトラブル
苦しみしか生まれてこない
その判断する基準を壊さなくちゃいけない
なぜ判断するかというと
やはりものがあるという錯覚
なぜものがあるという錯覚が生まれるかと
ものの流れの速さには気づいてない
気づくはずもない こちらもものであって
外の世界も同じものだから
同じ速さで動いて変化しているんだから
一定のものだと錯覚しますね
それは物理学の世界で考えても同じことで
同じスピードで車2つ並んで走るといつでも側にあるんだから
だから見るもの見られるものも同じ速さだから
見るものがあると思っちゃうんですね
消滅する速さが同じだからね
そういうわけで やっぱり集中力でもって
そこはちょっとそれ反らせてもらわないと
反れたところでそこはわかってしまう
だからそこをわかってない
だからものがあるという錯覚が生まれる
で あるということだから
自分もいるという錯覚が出てくる
そこであるものをいい悪いかと判断するようになってきます
その基準を壊さなくてはいけない
その基準を壊してしまった人にとっては
この世もあの世ものもそんな幻覚は存在しないんだという悟りの境地ですね
たとえの場合はこの芦の橋ですね
書いているの ナルセートン
ナル 芦でしょうね おそらく
竹のようなものなんですけど
まあその強いものじゃなくて
手でもすぐ切れる そういうもので
ほんのちょっとの橋が造ったならば
すごい勢いで水が流れてきちゃったらもうバラバラに壊れてしまっちゃうんです
ですから この この勢い
暴流に人を例えているのは
物の無常たるこの変化の勢いなんですよ
すごい勢いで物は変化していくんだっていうことをわかったら
もうあんなもう芦の橋みたいな驕慢というのはもう残るわけじゃない
壊れてきます で 五番目
まあこれはまああまりにも高い
もうすごい難しい意味だから
世俗的に日常生活で私たちはまあどのようにこれを役に立つようにしますかというと
あの この今言った言葉
この判断は災いの元だと
判断は災いの元やと思っておけば
自分の心はよりレベル高い人間になるんですね
それにもすっごく気をつけていないと
すごい知識的にはものすごい元気でないと
その状態にいることできない
すぐ感情が出てしまって
もうみんな爆発しちゃうんですよ
だから体疲れても いつでも知識だけはものすごい元気満々状態で保たなければいけないんです
だから体いくら疲れても
人が何か話しかけてくる
その疲れてるんだから何言ってんだってことそれでなってしまっちゃうんです
もうとっくに判断しているんですね
ですから 酒やら麻薬やらもう一切使わないで
ものすごくいつでも知識を磨いとけという
こうなってるんです 僕たりもしないでね
頑張らなくちゃいけない
まああの いくらか精神的な元気な時でもね
いろんな人と喋ったり
いろんな行動に移ったりするとね
まああの あまり判断に囚われないで行動すると
結構楽に物事を運べますね
何かやろうとする 何か問題があって
これを解決しなくちゃいけないんだと
頑張る時でもとにかくまあ判断してしまって
このように解決するぞと
それに囚われちゃうとすっごく苦しみが生まれてくるんですね
ですから この 判断は災いの元だと
ということで ものは無常だからね
ものは流れるんだ 変化するんだと
ということで どっちになってもいいとも悪いとも判断できません
自分が頑張ったことを解決しようとしたことは解決しなかった
だからまずかったというのは判断でしょうに
解決しました だから良かったと
それも判断でしょう 世の中です
良かったも どっちでもないんですからね
本当のところは そういうふうな人にとっては
すごくリラックスして楽に生きていられます
まあとりあえずそれこそすごく難しいかもしれませんだけど
まあただ軽々と判断は災いの元やとかね
呪文のように唱えて頭に入れておけば
まあそれなりにいくらかうまくいくかもしれません
で 五番目に行きます Yo
na ajjamā bhavesu sāraṃ vicinaṃ pupphaṃ iva udumbaresu So
bhikkhu jahāti ore pāraṃ urago jiṇṇaṃ iva tacchaṃ purāṇaṃ Yo
bhikkhu jahāti ore pāraṃ urago jiṇṇaṃ iva tacchaṃ purāṇaṃ
で Yo na ajjamā bhavesu sāraṃ bhava
っていうのは何でしょうかね
こちらの訳は  生存状態のうちに健康なものを見いだせない
で この諸々の生存状態のうちに健康というんですか
健康なものを見いだせないという言葉ですね
ポイントは で bhava
パーリ語でbhava sāra
その二つの言葉なんですよ bhavesu
っていうのは複数形で
ロケチウ形ですけども 「bhava
においては」というね 「
諸々のbhavaにおいては」 sāra
っていうのは「エッセンス」という「健康なもの」という
ものは見いだせない ajjamā
見いだせない で どういう意味かというと bhava
っていうのは「存在」っていうことなんですよ 「
生きる」っていうことなんですね
だから生命は すべての生命は生きることに必死なんです
人生は楽であろうか 苦であろうが
もうそちらには構わないで生きることには必死なんです
なんででしょうかね そんなにもなんで生命が生きかかるんですか
それは一瞬も考えないんですね
で 気が紛らわすというかね
まあ何て言いますか ポイントをごまかしちゃうんですね
逸らしちゃう で これは子供すごい上手にするんで
子供には答えられない質問したりすると
あるいは答えたくない質問をすると
ちっちゃな子に「なんであんたそっち泣くんでしょうか」と何か聞いてみてください
綺麗にごまかすんです
驚くほど問題はもう違う方向へ持っていくんです
すごい上手なんですね
だからそういうところでもう理解できますよ
このすべての人生のこと
だから人間の心の問題
まあ別に解決策は仏教経典からはもう簡単に得られますけど
人に喋るといろんな例を出して明確にわかりやすく喋らなくちゃ
それ大変なんですね 私のやり方というのは
子供からもう全部勉強してもらう
世の中のこと知らない
もう親の見守られて もう遊ぶことしか知らない
もう幼稚園にも行ってないぐらいの子供たちれば
ものすごい人生 人間やってるこのズルいことやらね
全部勉強になるんです
その働き なんで大人もやっているのね
でも一回だけ私やられたことがありますけどね
で そうやって決して答えたくない質問一つ
いつでもしゃぶってるんですね
自分の親指を 親指をしゃぶって同じ漫画を回でも見る
ドラえもんの漫画でも一回全部録画して見ているんですね
そこで気持ちよくソファに座ってじーっと見ているんですね
私もそばに座ってもいいんですか？と言って
そばに座って で これ それ
そんなにおいしいんですか？と聞いたんです
で 答えない じーっとあれ見てるんですね
美味しくないんだったら何かお醤油でもかけてあげようかと
お醤油かお塩とかどうですか？と聞いたら
指をしゃぶりながらいきなりこれ外して
なんて言いますかね 何そういうことしか考えられない
考えられないんですか？そういうことしか考えられないんですか？と言ってまた指をさして
瞬時なんですよ あっという間にそれ言って
また指を口に入れて またしゃぶって
またじーっと見ている
で 子供にとって自分も言ったことに
それって別にどうったことでも言った
終わった もう忘れた それで終わり
あの瞬間で現れてきた知恵の鋭さっていうのは驚いたんですよ
本当にもう もう完璧にもう負けてましたからね
だから だって本当のことだから
余計なことなんで考えるんですか
どうせもういいことで
子供が指をしゃぶろうが
だから負けたのはその一箇所だけなんですけど
でも他の まあいつでも子供にそうやってもう知恵が現れるってことはないんだけどね
もうかなりごまかす 十分ごまかすのは
その子がすごく上手なんですね
ものすごい上手 だから大人の意見
大人の意見 大人には自分の意見にはどうしてもその子もう負けてもらう
納得させてもらうってことは全く無理なんです
とにかくきれいに上手に自分の意見に負けてもらう
あんなまま大きくなったらとんでもないことになるかもしれない
教育やいろいろなことでね
もう脳細胞を壊されますから
将来どうかわかりませんだけどね
あのままだったらもう大変なことなんですけど
そこでこの言いたかったのは
この存在 なんで生きたがるんでしょうかということを
それは我々は答えないんです
それ置いておいて 買い物
買い物しなくちゃ 洗濯しなくちゃ
学校に行かなくてはならない
会社に行かなくちゃとかね
ローン払わなくちゃとかね
そうやって生きるために必要な道具に囚われているんです
なんでっていうことは聞かないんです
だから買い物に行くのは生きるためにあって
あれは道具であって 会社に行くのは生きるためであって
生きるための道具であって
なんでそんなに必死な思いで生きてるんですかと
なぜ生きていかなくてはならないんですか？っていうところには全然疑問は抱かないんです
生命は人間だけではなくて
誰でも それは全然当たり前
生きているんだから だって生きているんだから買い物をしなくちゃと
だって生きてるんだから洗濯しなくちゃと
ということで終わってしまっちゃうんですね
だからこの道具 が大変大事になって
仕事は関係ないんだと
だからその考え方は別に
ただ一般的に世の中を見ても同じことなんです
今我々はこのすごい発展している世界で生きているんだと威張ってるんだけど
今は人間生きてるんじゃないんです
人間は奴隷化になっているんですね
道具の 我々は生きるために作った道具に操られて
今道具に合わせて生活しているんです
それでさらに複雑な道具を作る
作って さらにそれに合わせるんですね
だからもともとは人生に合わせて道具を作ったんですよ
昔はこの自然の中で火を発見して
火に焼かれたものを食べたところで
ああ 美味しかったと 生で食べるよりはと
それで自分にとっては焼いて食べた方がいいと
でも火がないんですね
そこで自分のために火を発見するでしょう
なんとかね まあ枝を削ったりとか
石でなんとかしたりとか
いろいろやり方で火を発見する
で 一旦火の火の玉を作ったところでどうなるかというと
これなかなか大変だから
消えちゃったらね それで
そのために生活をまた変えなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
だからこの昔 そういう風になったんですよ
すごい大変苦労しながら
火の玉というんですか
あれを守り続けなくてはならなかったんです
だからその瞬間で道がずれてしまったんですね
そこでどんどん道具が発展してきて
今この石 2つだけの道具じゃないでしょうに
昔は石1つ  2つだけの道具で石器時代で生活したんだけど
その石 2つ  3つだけの人生っていうのは
今は少々変わって だから
いかに我々は道具のために生きているかということは
聞こうとも見ようともしないんですね
我々は朝起きる時間も
食べる時間も すべて道具のために決めているんです
寝る時間も 道具で決めてるんです
自分で決めることはないんです
そんなに生きること大事だったら
自分寝たい時間に他のものを合わせればいいのに
自分食べたい時間に他のものを合わせればいいのに
例えば朝方眠い人がいるでしょうに
ダメでしょ 会社に行くんだったら
そんな甘えていられませんと言って
とにかく苦労して朝起きて
電車で居眠りしながら会社に行く
だから守っている生命自体そのものがいじめちゃってるんですよ
一番恐ろしいのはコンピューター
IC のこの文化なんですね
とことん人生決めてるんです
だからこの  2000何とかミレニアムバグですか
日本語で何て言いますかね
2KY問題とかね いろいろ言葉作っちゃって
2000年になったらコンピューター狂っちゃうんではないか
狂ったら文化そのもの
人生そのもの狂ってしまっちゃいますから
だからもうどうなるかわかりませんだけど
まあいろいろ工夫してもう頑張ってるんだけど
まあどうしようもないぐらい
まあ難しい問題で で とにかくそうやって
今我々は道具のために生きている
道具は何のためか知りませんと
それでこの仏教の世界ではね
まあそういう世俗的な考え方ではないんだから
世俗的な世界ではいかに道具を作るかっていうことに専念しているんですね
どれぐらい畑作るか どれぐらい牧するが
何を植えるかとかね どういう品物を作るか
どんな商売するかとか
まあそこは世俗的な世界で
仏教の世界で そういうまあパン食べるかご飯食べるか肉ということに結論判断する世界ではないんです
パンもご飯も道具であって
それは世俗的な世界ではパンは体にいいか
ご飯は体にいいか そちらで喧嘩すればいいんです
道具の奴隷だから 仏教の世界では
なんで生きてるんですかと
なんで道具作ってるんですかと
それぐらい道具まで作って生きているのはどういうわけかと
アホではないかと 道具作って道具にやられているんではないかと
道具ありすぎて仕事できないんだと
だから道具作った仕事は何ですかと
まあわかりやすいけど
いろんなところでねじ曲がってる刃物はあるとする
これ刃物であること確かなんで
これで何を切るんですかとわからない場合はね
無意味でしょうね 我々持っている道具はだいたいそういうもので
道具あるんだけど 何のためかとわからないんですよ
実際どんな 例えばテレビがあるんだ
あれは何のためですかね
何かあれで教えてくれと
何も教えてくれませんよ
だからこの ただカメラマンがいい加減にきれいな映像を流すだけで
情報は流れてきません
言ってるのは全部嘘で
全て嘘 ほとんど嘘 ものすごい醜い連中がね
すごい綺麗に映してもらう
だからあのテレビ出る人々はそれをもう知っていて
モニターがきちんと見ているんですよ
常にモニター見て喋ってるんです
それでちゃんと自分に合わせてるカメラの電気がつけた途端
すごいいい格好してて
電気切れちゃったら何のことなくかっこ悪くいる
まあたまには見ることは
できますからね 見学に行ってもいいんです
ABCD とかね カメラに番号振ってあって
上大きな赤いランプが小さな赤いランプがあって
編集室で 1本のビデオに全部このカメラから出てくる情報をさっさっさって決めて決めて一本にするんです
瞬時にやっちゃいますけど
あれかなりプロでないとできませんだけどね
そこでこの編集室の人々
何やってるかと この下の人々知りません
そこで向こうは撮っている瞬間は
そのカメラの赤いランプはついてつくんです
でもカメラマンはいつでもカメラを調節して合わせているんです
カメラマンにはそのスイッチ入れることはできない
それケーブルで繋げているんです
コントロールルームに
そこでカメラマンはいつでもカメラを人に合わせて
喋る人に合わせて こっちに合わせてあちらに合わせているんです
で コントロールルームでこれ撮るあれ撮る
16番  17番  5番とサササとスイッチ押して押して押していってるんです
そこで放送用のビデオが出来上がっちゃうんです
だから外で撮影しちゃうと
片っ端から撮って撮って持っていって
全部流して そこから 1番あそこからと
こうやって編集するんです
その分時間をかけてゆっくり編集できるんだけどね
そこであるものないものを作られますからね
ディジタル化時代だから
より嘘を作られるんです
一緒にいなかった人を一緒にいたようにする ことは何のことなくできるんです
そこで何のためかと 逆に人間に忙しいでしょうに
忙しい忙しいと言っていて
と言いながら テレビは何のためかというと
人間の時間を無駄に使うため
忙しいんだったらもうそんなことやめた方がいいのに
ラジオもテレビも 今日の出来事
それだけ放送して終わりと
仕事しなさいと あんた方忙しいでしょうに
だから 世の中の理屈を言うんだから
やっぱり道具作るんだけど
何のためかとわからない
だから仏教でというのは
なんで生きてるんですかと
それは仏教だけ聞いてる質問なんだよ
宗教で聞いてないんで
宗教でも なんであんたそんなに必死な思いで
そう苦労しながら泣きながら
なんでそんな生きてるんですかと
わかりませんと 考えたらどうですかと
で 宗教の世界では だから私は仏教と宗教を一線引きするのは
そういう嫌なのはそれなんですよ
宗教ではもうあれも前提として生きることはもう認めて
良い素晴らしい生きることを提案する
良い幸福な永遠な生き方を提案する
問題は見てないんですね
なんで生きてるんですかと
だから麻薬売ってる人はもうそれで人が死んじゃいますよとかね
まあ毒まで入っていても
もう売ってしまって生活して
そういう人は考えませんだからね
子供たちからみんなもう人生をバラバラに無茶苦茶にして
金儲けでどうなるんですか？考えてもお金が入るんだからということでやってるでしょうに
同じなんですよ 宗教にしたっても
生きていることは何のためかと考えるのではなくて
良い永遠な豊かな天国を提案する
そこは俗人が希望しているものなんです
道具作りながら 作りながらよりより安定した生き方を希望しているんだから
だからその世俗的な流れの人々が希望しているものに品物を一つ作って売っているだけで
だったら酒飲みたい人に酒を売っていることと同じなんです
悪いことをしたがっている子供たちに麻薬売ったりするのは
それと全く同じことなんですね
子供たちはもう世界にすごい興味だから
やっぱりやってみたいと
あれもやってみたいという気持ちが自然に生まれてくる
それで誰かがそういうことをやらせちゃう
という同じことで 別にそんなに差があるわけじゃないんです
だから極厳密に考えるとね
だからこの仏教お釈迦様だけ
この問題はね まあ生きるということは
ババっていうことはどういうものかと
と観察したんですね ですから
なんで生きるかと 必死の思いで
なんで生きてるんですかと
何かありますかと 生きて
何かあるんだったら誰か見つかったんですかと
見たらみんな死んだだけなんですよ
見つからないままに 途中で
みんな途中でゲームオーバーになっちゃうんですね
だってやること毎日ご飯食べる
仕事をする 寝る また起きてご飯食べる
寝る お風呂に入る それしかやってないんだからね
見つかるわけじゃないし
忙しいんでそれに それで途中でゲームオーバーで死んじゃうんですね
だから何か見つかったんですかと
見たらみんな連中死んでるだけなんですね
見たら だからこれはおかしいと
そういうわけで この出家主義とかね
このジャータカ物語の中で
王様も全部国まで捨てて森に入ったとか
このそういうストーリーはその土台からできちゃうんですよ
王様が子供がなくても
ありったけの神社やら神々にお祈りしてお祈りして
15年経ったところでやっと子供一人が授かりましたと
その子が生まれたところで
大喜びで国ごとに まあもう跡継ぎが
王子様が生まれたんだ
生まれたんだと大事に育てたんだけど
その子は 14歳になったところで
15歳になったところで
全部捨てて森に入ったということで
ストーリーができる そういうジャータカ物語いっぱいあるんです
だからそこはまあ悪く使う人々はやっぱり寄付しなさい
寄付しなさい 全部全部財産捨てなさいとか
あそこってそんなもういい加減な人々に使う物語ではないんですよ
そちらにすごい深い真理があって作るものなんですね
あるストーリーで このこの寿命は長いんだと
当時で人々の場合には
ですから 子供の時は 4万8万4000年
子供として遊んでるんだと
若い時で子供の時期 青年の時期
そこで若い時期も中年の時期も 4万8000年
それで老後ですか また 4万8000年生きてるんだ
それで王様がいて  4万8000年間遊んだりして
勉強して遊んだりして
それから王になって 自分の髪の毛を
まあなんていう嘛 散髪している
まあそういう家来の人がいるんだから
その人にある日ね まあもし髪の毛が白くなったら私に言ってくださいと
最初に言っておいたんだと
王になったら特別な線職専門の人が
それで毎日決まってる人しか触れませんだからね
王様の髪の毛を だからそれはもし
白い毛が白髪が出たら言ってくださいと言われたんだと
そこで長い長い年月経ったところである日
一本の髪の毛が白くなってしまった
それでその人は王様  1本の白髪がありますよと言ったら
あ それ取ってください
取って出してくださいと
言って自分の手でもらったそうです
もらったら それ見てものすごく怖くなって怯えたんだと
ああ 人生終わりだと こんなくだらんことをやっている暇はないんだと
言って 何のこともその人に言わないで
ちゃんと王様としてかっこよく全部できて
まあ仕事ですか このいろいろまあなんとか玉座に座って大臣たちをまとめられたところで
今日は発表ありますと
特別に 王様の特別な発表が何でしょうみたいな
今日からこの王位に私の息子を決めますと
私は王位から降りますと
それはみんなびっくり
ものすごい若い もう元気な人が何で降りるんですか？そしたらどういうわけかと
王様死にかけているんだと
今日はもう白い 1本の髪の毛が見つかりましたと
ただ 国民も大臣たちも泣くんだそうですね
その場合 あんたはまたまた４人
もう老後もまた４ ４ まあ万 ８
万４千年あるんじゃないかと
まだまだもう途中なんで
もう若いうちなんで で
出家してどうするんです
いえいえ そんなことをまあ気にしないと
もうとにかく死ぬんです
全部捨てて森に入ると
だからなんでそういうストーリーが出てくるかというと
やっぱり毎日同じワンパターンでバカなことをやって
みんなゲームオーバーで死んじゃうということなんですよ
ここをそこまでやって
なんで生きてるんですか？という質問に気が行かないんですね
だからそこを考えなさいと
あの分かりやすいストーリーで言ってることなんですね
あと人生寿命は 4万8000年
8万4000年残ってやったっても
あんたはゲームオーバーで終わりますよと
何か見つかりっこはないんだと
なぜならば 世俗世界っていうのは道具作っては困る
道具作っては困る 道具作っては困るという世界なんですね
そういうわけで 仏教という宗教というのは確実に人生に必要なものなんです
我々にはただ食べて寝て死ぬだけのことではなくて
もう一つ考えなくてはならないことがあるんだと
だってそこをしっかりする場合は
やっぱりブッダの教えとして
みんなもう何も疑問も何も思わないで
みんな堂々と 例えばこのままブルッダね
タイアーラ まあタイアーラなんてこと言ってみたでしょう
そういうところでもみんなもうバリバリと仕事をしながら
もうお寺にももう来る
もう仕事終わっても もう何にでも来る
朝仕事に行く前にお寺に来て
なんとかなんとかお接待でもしてもう帰るとか
もう一緒になってるんですよ
生きることと仏教っていうのは
隠れてやるものじゃなくて
威張ってやるんです 自分たちが正しい道を捕まってるんだと
まあ一応 別に瞑想して悟っているというわけじゃなくて
もういわゆる生きる目的見つかってるんですね
生きていなくちゃいけないんだと
なぜならば この道を歩まなくちゃいけないんだと
そこで喜んで まあ頑張ってはいるんだけどね
まあそれにしてもそれはもう意味ですけど
やっぱりちゃんと観察して心を清らかにしない限りは意味がないんですけどね
とにかくそれでも一応道に入って
その喜びを 充実感を感じている
だからそういう人々は仕事の苦しみは感じないんです
全然感じない あのシンガポールのあの仏教図書館のもう副館長やってる人ってのは
もう若いうちに もう本当に立派なお医者さんでしたからね
もう辞めたと 何のことなく辞めて
図書館で毎日仕事してて
ジブリ村のそれそうでもない
よくやりますからね だから何もまずいことをしたんだとかね
みんなに何か言われるんではないかとかね
あんた変ではね おかしいと
そんなもう気にしない
誰も言いません みんな驚くだけなんです
普通だったら まあ年取るまでどこかで仕事をして
もう 金儲けて生活するだけのことなんですけど
そういうふうな生き方もあったけど
とにかくこのなぜ生きるか
生きているかっていう問題も聞かなくちゃいけない
だからお釈迦様はその問題を提案して
その道を教えてあげた
で それ死ぬ前にやらなくちゃいけないんだから
死ぬ前に生きてなくちゃいけない
だから仕事をしなくちゃいけないんです
仕事をしながら ご飯食べながら
そういうことをやらなくちゃいけないんですね
死ぬのは別にそんな大したことじゃないんだから
いつでも死ねるんだからね
だから死ぬ前にこれも発見しなくちゃいけない
なぜ生きているんですか？ということは
そういうわけで 世俗的な生き方と仏教の出世間的な生き方は何のことなく成立するんです
ぶつかることはないんです
宗教の場合はぶつかっちゃうんです
永遠の命をいただくためには
いろんなものを here で捨てなくちゃいけないんです
生きる楽しみもすべて
例えば カトリック教の神父さんたちがすごい苦労しているでしょうね
シスターたちも ものすごい苦労したり
修行したり 頑張ってますけどね
かなりもう損しているんです
同じことやってるのに
酒売ってる人と同じことやってるのに
ただ苦しんでるんですね
彼らがやっぱり性を正当化しているんだからね
生きることは まあまあ当たり前で素晴らしいことだ
だったら永遠の命を抱こうと
そのためにこの仮の命をバカにしようと
一時的な この人間としての人生をバカにしてやるぞということで
本当は聖書ではね 結婚するなと言ってないんでしょうね
神父さんたちは結婚しないんです
修行しなさいと全然言ってないんです
やってるんです まあとにかく
で こちらでのこのバヴァ・ムサラン
この結局この問題探ったところで
なぜ生きているかと そこまでして生きている意味があるかと探したところで
何も んーと 堅固？堅固でしたっけ？そう
堅固なものは見つからなかったと
ただの空っぽでしたと
空しでしたと と見つかる
バカバカしい それであの必死に生きていなくちゃ
生きていなくちゃと 人殺してでも生きていなくちゃと
大量殺人してでも自分の政治家として権力を守らなくちゃという
あのアホらしさっていうのはもう全部消えちゃうでしょうね
[背景の雑音]そこであの巨大な火が消えたような感じで
サーッと心が 心のあの大火事が消えちゃうんです
だからそれも一つの悟りの表現で
そういう風にも悟りを表現できる
渇愛という言葉でも悟りのことを表現できる
2番目に出てきた慢というね
今 狂慢 判断 判断という一言葉でも悟りのことを表現できる
この一つ一つ言葉っていうのは
ものすごい膨大な思想なんです
で 例えも面白い例えで
この花が咲かない木がありますね
これパーリ語では何と言いますか
ウドンバラという木なんですけど
実がありますけど 花が咲かないんですね
花はない そこでウドンバラという木がある
森の中で花を探す 落ちてる花でもないんですか？とかね
いくら探しても見つかりません
花が咲きません だから
で 日本で言えばイチジクでしょうかね
イチジクですか イチジクでも花が咲きませんでしょ
花が咲かない そう聞いたけど
イチジクは花が咲かない
だから花が咲かない木はあるわけじゃなくて
生物学的には花が咲きますよ
でも花も実も一緒なんですね
だから小さい時も実がなるように見えるんですね
中には花があるんだけどね
それで大きくなって それは実なんです
それを取って食べればいいんです
普通の生活は花が咲いて
花が落ちて それから実がなる
そういう風に落ちている花がないかと探しても見つからないんだという
また単純な例えなんです
ですから 花が咲かないというふうに即的な
まあ取ればいいんです
別に学問的にいかなくても
だからこの イチジクの林でもいいし
ウドンバラの林でもいいし
とにかくイチジクの林に行って落ちている花がないかなと探したっても見つからないんだ
そのように生きることに何か大変大事な何かあるかと探しても見つかりませんという
見つからなかった人は
ないということは確認した人
ないんだと そこでホッとして
何にもとらわれない この世にもあの世にも存在にとらわれない状態は
悟りの状態なんです はぁ
疲れます 6番
ヤッサヤッサンタラトーナナサンティコーパーイティバワーバワタムチェヴィヴィヴィティワットソービックージャハティオーラターランウラゴージンネニワタチャンプラーナーン
ヤッサンタラトーナサンティコーパーイティバワーバワタムチェヴィーティワットソービックージャハティオーラターランウラゴージンネニワタチャンプラーナーン
こちらポイント 2つあります
ヤッセアンタラトーネサンティコーパン
これは日本訳と同じで
アンタラトーっていうのは心の中
自分の中なんですね コーパ
怒りがないと 物にぶつかることをしない
怒りが心の中から出てくるんだからね
怒りも欲望も心の中から出てくるものですけど
心の中で怒りがきれいさっぱり消えてる
だから怒りに すべての説法は前に渇愛についてした説法と同じものだからね
また繰り返す必要ないんです
怒りが生まれるっていうのは
入ってくる情報 好ましくないと判断したら
それを攻撃することですね
で その攻撃したがる悪いものをやっつけるぞと
という気持ちが消えちゃうと
だから中にあるんです
悪いものをやっつけると
やっつけていいものを残しちゃうという
それは怒り だから普通世の中でこの世直しに
世直しに出る人々のもう本当はあれ怒りの感情なんです
本当かどうかわかりませんだけど
一応怒りの感情なんで
悪いものは全部直してやるぞと
とにかく行動にすること自体はもう何かありきなんですよ
いい行動したって悪い行動したって
どこかで苛立ちがあるんです
落ち着いていられないんです
うん まあこの悪いものいけないもの
放っておけなくて 何か直したくて
壊したくて そういう風にいく
それも怒りの衝動で まあとにかく心の中にそういうことがありまして
入る耳に音が入ると 音は嫌だったらとにかくなんとかして
それも音を遮断しようと
放っておこうということではないんですね
で 窓を閉めたり それでも入るんだったら隣の家に行って文句言ったりとかする
もう完全なる怒りなんですね
放っておくっていうことはできない
で 野良猫が入ったりすると
またペットボトルに水を入れてずっと置いておくとかね
猫を遮断しようと それは怒りの行動
で 猫はペットボトルは怖くて逃げるんですね
よくあれ 人間一度も猫はそんなこと気にしません
おしっこまでかけちゃいますよね
その上に あの水かけて入れてるペットボトルの上平気で歩いてるのに
みんないっぱいあれやってると
ものすごい私には怒りにはかなり怒ってるなと
そんなことでやりきれないでしょうに
いくら頑張っても そこであの自分の国で昔あったんだけど
この塀っていうんですか
フェンスなんか それはレンガで作ったりもしますね
で レンガで作られて上
この別にまあ向こうは原始的な世界だから
一番上は あの 特にみんな嫌がるところの子どもたちがそれもう捕まっても飛んだり登ったりする
それが嫌で あの一番上にこのガラスの破片
この割れたボトルとかね
綺麗に植えておくんですね
で 触ることできない ちゃんと見えるように
綺麗かどうかわかりませんだけど
いろんなまあもういろんな方向に変えて変えて
この割れたガラス瓶やらガラスからこうやっていろんなもうささっとセメントの上に埋め込む
で まあ人間はそれ触って登らなくちゃいけないんだ
ですから 人間の手は切れるかもしれません
だから人間が登ろうとしない
猫なんかね 間で平気で歩いて
うちの黒猫がね 隣の家の塀を歩くんで
隣の奥さんが怒り出して
塀の上に秒を全部張ったんです
猫は怪我しなかったんだけど
隣の奥さんがドア開けて捕まって怪我した
でも私しょうがなく謝りに行ったんですけどね
猫は全然怪我してない
猫はいる そこで子供たち登るの嫌がるやるでしょうに
子供たちは何にも 何か棒を一本持ってきて
登るだけではちゃんちゃんと叩いて登ったりする
だからこんなことはもう避けられないんです
我々はドアの鍵ちゃんとかけたとか確かめたりするでしょうね
いとも簡単にどんな鍵も開けられますね
ものすごい出来が悪いんですよ
今の鍵っていうのは あまりにもありすぎて
鍵はなかった時代で 一つ二つ特別に作って工夫して
その鍵でないと開けられないということはあったんだけど
だから昔々の鍵見たことがあるんでしょうか
すごい重いんです 今 自分の寺の本堂の鍵なんかはかなり重い
まあ四キロ五キロぐらい
あれは何とか言って開けることできませんよ
あれ その鍵ないと 今スリランカの場合は古い文化だから
お寺の鍵っていうのは
お寺っていうのはほとんど本堂の鍵なんですけど
あれは尊敬の気持ちもあって
かなり大きく作るんです
真鍮のものです 塊作って
この鍵のあれ あの 何て言いますか
開けるところはあれ あれもすごく太くて
まあ四センチぐらい幅があったりとかね
だからあれは大きなあのハンカチみたいでっかいやつをスカーフのような
あれぐらい大きなもので
ちゃんと結んで こうやって背中に乗って持っていくんです
本堂を開ける場合は 古いお寺だったら
あれは一つの儀式のようなものなんですね
これから来るぞということで
ちゃんと儀式をやっても丁寧に開けると
あれはお釈迦様に対する信仰でもってでっかい鍵作ってますけど
昔はもう大体鍵作る家ではあれぐらい大きい鍵を作るんです
じゃあ泥棒開けてみようとしても開けられません
今はなんでしょうかね
ありすぎて ですから 鍵かけたんだからといって
自分の家はもう空き巣に入ることはないということはない
入るんだったら入ると
で 火事にならないように
いくら重り家中に張ってあったっても
隣の家が火事になったらどうしますか？この家にも移ってしまっちゃいますからね
だからまあこんなやりきれないんですよ
だからそれに怒りの感情出す人はすっごい苦労する
ものすごい苦労する人生になっちゃうんですね
だから世界はもう遮断しようと
自分の希望通りにということで
だから答えはそれじゃないんです
ほっと合うとなんです
僕みたい野良猫が来たら挨拶するんです私は
あ 猫ちゃんおいでとか元気？ご飯食べた？とかね
いろいろ聞くんで一回しか来ないんです
出て行けと追い出しちゃったら
必ず窓のところか玄関のところへちゃんと空気の通るところ見ておしっこかけるんだから
あれでも 3ヶ月間以上臭いんだから
どんな薬で消したってあの悪臭は消せません
私は少々猫よりはもう頭働かせて挨拶する
挨拶したら猫はもう出てこない
で よっぽどの猫だったらね
いわゆるあまり人を怖がらない
もう元気な猫だったらたまってくるかもしれません
それだけこちらも毎日挨拶すればいいんです
そうするとお互いに顔見知りなんです
おしっこかけません それだったら野良猫でもちょっと食べ物あったらあげたっていいことになっちゃうんですね
猫は夜吠え始めたら 私はもうあっち行けとか何のことなくね
あんた方はね この合唱団はね
昼やったらどうですか？とか
何のことなく面白おかしく喋ってるんですね
それで相手は全然怒ってないと
自分たちの行動に攻撃してないとわかるんですね
それでなんとなくこの契約みたいなものが立ち上がっちゃう
成り立っちゃうんですね
邪魔しない 遠く行くか
やめるか だからやっぱりこの攻撃することで問題を解決しないんです
[背景の音楽]でも人間っていうのはどんなものにも攻撃する性格がついちゃったらもうすごい苦労する
ものすごい火が燃えちゃう心の中で
ですから この心の中でこの攻撃したがる気持ちを消してもらう
イティ・バヴァ・アティ・バヴァ・バヴァタン・チッ・ヴィーティワット
イティ・バヴァ・バヴァタンっていうのはこの疑いのことで
いわゆる妄想のことはね
妄想っていうのは何でも妄想できますよ
妄想って思うことなんです
私はあれはあんまり良くないと思いますねとかね
まあ結構なかなかいいものだと思いますよとかね
勝手に何を思ったってもいいんだからね
私はあの人は信頼できないと思いますけど
もう一人 まあそうではないと思いますけどとかね
いえいえ ものすごい信頼できますよと
そうやって我々の心の中で何かにとりついて
どんなものも思えるんです
よく聞くで あんたどう思います？あんたどう思いますか？あんたどう思います？どうでもいいんですよ
本当のところ あんた思うことだからね
それであんた思うことじゃなくて
自分の思うこともそういうことなの
どうでもいいんです だから他人には言いやすいんだけど
これは悟りには恥ずからない
自分に言わなくちゃね
自分の思うことはどうでもいいんです
だから これ妄想の世界で考えることの世界で
我々はやっぱり宇宙は無限大だとか思ったりする
いえ 有限だとも勝手に思えと
どっちでもいいんだから
関係ないんだからね 存在は永久的に生き続くの？勝手に思いなさい
いろんなこと いえ 存在は死んじゃったらすぐピタッと消えるんだ
そうやっていろんな宗教哲学生まれるでしょ
それもインドでは六十四種類のね
宗教哲学があって 魂にはオリジン
何て言いますか 魂はある日いつか生まれたんだと
これを生まれたんだと私は思う
それでその思う連中の中であれは突然生まれたと私は思いますよと
もう一人 私はあの魂はある日突然じゃなくて
神が作ったと思いますよと
だから神が作ったんだから
神がそうと永久的になくっちゃいけないんですよ
それで神がの魂は不死なるも永遠で
これ作ったもんだから
これどこかで止まるでしょうと
そうやって哲学作るんですよ
あるんだから そういう宗教哲学は
神は永遠であって 人間はそうでないと
でも人間には魂があるんです
その魂が神が勝手に吹き込んだことやとかね
だから人間が死んじゃう
なしあればある日創ったんだから
スタートポイントありますから
ラストポイントもありますと
スタートポイントがありますから
終わるポイントもあるんだと
スタートポイントがないんだから
終わるポイントも神にはないんだと
これスタートポイントは神が作ったと思う人々はそう思う
いえ 突然現れたんだという人は神を否定しますね
突然 そうやっていろんなものは人間が思ったりしますね
キリがないんですよ それに付け加えてもう一つの概念を入れることもできます
それに付け加えてもう一つ入れることもできますよね
例えば神は永遠であって
作ったものはこの時間の感覚の中で作ったものだから
神にとって我々のことはどうでもいいんだと
嫌だったらそれを壊す
また新しいものを作る
それを壊してまたものを作る
ですから 私たちは自分がでしゃばってあれやろうと思っても意味がないんだと
勝手に生きましょう やりたい放題なことをやって
神なんか関係ないというふうにも思えるでしょうに
もう一つ そういうと いや
違いますよと 神が自分で作ったものだから
我々のことを大事にしていますよ
だって人は稲を植えたら
すごい稲を大事に守るではないかと
羊に例を出しますからね
羊飼いはすごい自分の羊を守るでしょうに
狼から だから我々のことを大事に守ってるんだから
やっぱり 神に関してのことでもある人が言えるという
ある人は同じ理屈を概念を借りて
やっぱり神が勝手に作ったんだから勝手に壊す
また嫌だったらまた作ってまた壊す
別に我々はもううんというも関係ないというふうに無視しようという概念も生まれる
いくらでも世の中でいろんなものがそうやっていろんな考え方あるでしょうに
それ私がそう思うってことでしょうに
結局は 思うことはいろんなことをできます
私はフランス料理は一番美味しいと思うとかね
もう一人はやっぱり中華料理の方が美味しいと
勝手に思えばいいんです
思った人はそれを付けちゃうんですよ
だってフランスっていうのは食文化だから
中国の中国って何ですか？これもう四千年の古い文化だからと
ゴキブリでも食べる方法を知ってるんだと
フランス人は何て言いますか
エスカルゴ 気持ち悪い動物
あれぐらいしかわからないと
食べ方は と言える場合はいくらでも言えるでしょうに
だからお互いにそこで意見の喧嘩になってしまっちゃっている
そのようにものすごいありったけの世の中の思考
考え方っていうのは 全て結局は私がそう思っているところから生まれるもんなんですね
そこは仏教の煩悩の世界で疑という一言葉にまとめています
疑 ミチゲッチャという
知らないんだから思うだけで
知ってるんだったらもうないんだからね
だからこの科学的でなくて
科学的にはもうやっぱり自分で実感
客観的に捕まえて調べて計算して
もう結果出せるぐらいだったらしっかりしているでしょうにね
そうでないものまで人間っていうのは思考を伸ばしちゃうんですよ
だから医学の世界ではいろんなことを工夫するんだけど
いまだに体のコントロールできないんですね
薬は作るんだけど 効くか効かないかはわからない
どんな風に患者さんが
の体が反応するかわからない
一応試してはみる それで医学者か科学者であるならばね
そこで止まればいいんですよ
一応こういう病気にはこういう薬なんですけど
まあ効く場合も効かない場合もあると
一応手術はしますけど
うまくいけば治りますよと
わからないんだと 本当は
例えばお腹切ったり胸切ったりするでしょ
この傷跡をつなげるかつなげないかってことわかります？医者は
つなげない時もあります
切って またもう殺菌して
もうこうやって張っていきますけど
つなげない とすると大変なことでしょうに
ですから  そこでもうわからないと知らないと言うんじゃなくて
みんなやっぱり何か言うんでしょうね
やっぱり命っていうのは不思議なものやとかね
あの人はもう末期なのに良くも治りましたとね
末期だとわかって 最初からわかってなかったでしょうに
ただ推測で まあこれこれぐらいもうできてるんだから
まあそこで計算して まああと半年でしょうとかね
そのできてる週っていうのは
まあその 1週間 2週間で死ぬものだったらであるかわからないでしょうに
細胞っていうのは死ぬもんだからね
まあとにかくそこで命は不思議やとかね
尊い命にはなんとかなるし
何もしてあげてはいけないとかね
まあいろんなことをもう余分に考えたりする
そこからまたいろんな新しい信仰やら古い信仰を蘇ることやら
いろんなこと出ていく
とにかく世の中の人間の一切の思考
概念 哲学というのは まあこの私がそう思うということなんです
思うんだったら何でも思える
別にどうってことない
何でも思える この人を可愛いと思えば可愛いんですよ
可愛くないと ないと思ってやったら可愛くないんですから
それで可愛いと思ったところで
なぜ可愛かった理由を探すんですよ
こういうわけで可愛いと
可愛くないと思った瞬間で可愛くないという思いを成立するために理由を探しちゃう
ばっかりったことなんです
で こういうわけで こういうわけで可愛いんだと
こういうわけで こういうわけで可愛くないんだと
例えば人と結婚する場合は
こういうわけで こういうわけで
ものすごい可愛いんだと
すごい信頼できるんだと
結婚して で そこでもう可愛くないと思ったところで
まあ離婚するために必要なこと
まあこういうわけで こういうわけで可愛くないんだから離婚するんだと
随分もう自由自在好き勝手なんです
だからこの心の状況 私がこう思うというところの中に何があるかというと
疑い わかってない っていうこと
イティ・バヴァ・バヴァっていうことでパーリ語で出てくるのは
このようにある あったんではないか
このようにあったんではないかというふうな世界
だからここで何か人々の考え方そのものを取って
用語を作っている イティ・バヴァ・バヴァン
イティ・バヴァ・バヴァっていうのは専門用語なんです
いわゆる疑という煩悩に使っている言葉なんですね
そうではなかった そうではないか
ああではないかと思う状態
心にある状態 推測でもない
推測 いいです その状態をヴィッティヴァッと全部なくしてしまったと
だからなんで怒りとこの概念がついてきたんですか？と
こちらもちょっと意味があるんですよ
みんなものすごいこの喧嘩するのは概念を持っといて喧嘩するんです
[ページをめくる音]食べたご飯おいしくなかったんだからということで
それほど怒りが生まれてこないんです
例えば 焼き魚食べてたところで
奥さんがすごい塩かけすぎて
本人がその上お醤油もかけて口に入れたらもう塩辛くてもうびっくりしたんだと
これにばっかみたく喧嘩しようとしないんです
ものすごく鬼みたいに怒るということは
よっぽどの阿呆でないと怒らないんです
でも 概念についてはそうじゃないんです
すぐ爆発しちゃうんです
概念というのは私がそう思うということだからね
それと怒りつなげておいてるんですね
この焦点では だからわかりやすく言えば
あの人はこう思っている
この人はこう思っている
私はこう思っている どっちでもいいやという
何の根拠もない もうただそう思っている
それだけなんです 突然
時々ヨーロッパ人とか伝世人なんて会った時に
いきなり私は神様いると思います
ああそう 私の反応は それだけ
それで話進まないんです
よく言うんですよ 会ったら
私は神様がいると思います
ああそう それで終わっちゃうんです
勝手に思えっていうことで
それでどうしても話 それで会話ちょうだいになりますから
やっぱり向こう側がまた世間のこととかね
あんた方はどのように思っているかとかね
で 聞いたりすると まあ我々はこういうふうにこういうふうに思ったりしますよっていうふうに私もしますけどね
うん さあ やっぱり五番までいきますか
[紙をめくる音]